now you may be wondering why we repeat
the prayers repetitively Let Me Explain
real quickly for you guys who don't know
scripture and you butcher the words of
the Lord in Matthew
6 repetitive prayer repeating prayers
right repetitive meditation on the Bible
is a form of spiritual exercise I need
you to listen it's a form of spiritual
exercise God has designed you that the
more you say something the more you do
something
you will then be enable to make it
second nature a part of your very DNA so
that now it becomes so engraved in
you that it just flows instinctively
that's with every discipline in life any
discip martial arts boxing what do they
do they keep having you Jill the same
movements over and over again teaching
they teach you the alphabets and because
God designed the human mind to pick up
something when it's done repetitively
and now it becomes a part of your very
psychological physiological makeup so
repeating the prayers with meditation
the more you do that the more you will
be able by the Holy Spirit Illuminating
you to understand the words you recite
and it becomes second nature that even
when you're
not making an effort to recite the
prayers it keeps playing in your mind
and the more you have God's word playing
in your mind the less sinful thoughts
because the Bible says John 15:3 our
Lord spoke to the disciples and he said
you are already clean because of the
word I have spoken Psalm 1199 tells us
that a man will keep his ways clean by
his word so the more God's word is
playing in my mind and my thoughts the
less sinful thoughts and Cravings I will
have so we want to reach a level where
we are so saturated with the words of
God and these prayers that every thought
we have is simply focused on the beauty
of our God his Holiness his glory and
his character so I don't have time to
think of lust or food or sin this is the
purpose of repetitive repetitive prayer
it is spiritual training exercise
you with me
there exactly it's like working out the
more I do push-ups sit-ups the more I do
benches and squats the more I walk the
leaner I get the more muscular I
get so that's with the spiritual life
and I've given you verses on this I've
shown you from the Bible where Paul
Likens the spiritual life to a race to
Olympics to boxing First Corinthians
9:24-27
okay you with me there
so don't let anyone deceive you oh
Matthew 6 Jesus said do not you know
like the pagans vain babbling yes he
says vain babblings uttering worthless
words over and over again these are not
vain words These Are Spiritual words
that give spiritual life and the more we
focus on them the more we'll be
transformed by
them you want me
there
yep
exactly would you rather have the words
of God the words of scripture these
prayers playing in your mind over and
over again or these Wicked evil filthy
thoughts that plague me may God destroy
my bondage to lust and food addiction
why do you think I succumb because my
thoughts it starts with a thought I
start thinking of food I start thinking
of lust and if I don't die to that and I
do not rebuke that and then change my
thinking to Something Beautiful then I
succumb and let me show you that from
scripture real quick are you
ready so don't let these idiots who
think they know the Bible Matthew 6 vain
repetition because in the Bible you're
going to see even Spirit creatures
repeating the same words you guys want
me to show you
that do you want me to show you from
scripture that Heavenly Creatures repeat
the same words same formula over and
over and over
again guys want me to show that
all right here let me show you so let's
go through this systematically right
here let me show
you all right let's set it up let me get
the verses I'll use New Standard Version
because I want to show you some nugget
from sirak and we go into the topic
thank you for making these channels
successful the Lord bless you if you're
not here I wouldn't be here but because
you're here the spirit is perfecting me
in my understanding so I can share the
word being his mouthpiece and may the
Holy Spirit give me perfect recall of
every jot to the poor scripture destroy
all error and sin us and take over our
entire beings and our loved ones my
daughters own us for the glory of Jesus
Christ Purge our mouths our tongues to
never beair deny disown or blasphemy
name of the Lord Jesus Christ and
Destroy every form of idolatry and
blasphemy we love you we cling to you we
worship you Holy Spirit okay glory to
the father Spirit now let me get you the
verses right Revelation 48 and the four
living creatures
watch each of them with six wings are
full of eyes around the inside day and
night without season
they sing without ceasing ceaselessly
they repeat the same words in song Holy
Holy Holy the Lord God the almighty who
was and is who is to come that means
they're violating the words of Jesus
huh they're violating the words of Jesus
right exactly Zach Mercer you know what
it is you're a
warrior you see what happens when you
put the Bible in wrong hands do you see
that guys before I move on I need you to
see it do you see where it says without
seizing they sang the same words over
and over again holy holy holy the Lord
God the almighty who was and is who is
to come now James White was there or
Anthony Rogers was there say hold on
wait wait wait wait what is it wait let
me interrupt no stop
stop
stop so can you imagine Jamila white and
Anthony Dodgers there Crystal stop what
are you doing what do you mean Matthew 6
no vain babbling how dare you and you're
doing the front of God's Throne God say
something see how
silly see how silly that
is all right now watch
here now watch here why repetitive
repetitive prayer fasting Bible
meditation
Church Eucharist
why here's why 1 Corinthians
9427 do you not know that in a race here
Paul is likening the Christian faith to
discipline here do you not know that in
a race the runners all compete but only
one receives the prize now look here
Paul is telling you the spiritual life
is training it's competition it's
discipline run in such a way that you
may win it you're in a a race and he has
in mind the Olympic Games they would
have these Olympic Games especially at
Corinth where people would would run in
a marathon for a prize a wreath that was
perishable so he's using the imagery of
the Olympic Games ironically right and
we're now seeing the Abomination that's
called the Olympics run in such a way
that you may win it athletes exercise
self-control and all things do you see
the Bible Likens the spiritual life to
training are you seeing with your own
eyes yes Musha that's where it comes
from
yep all right so here you go athletes
exercise self-control on things they do
it to receive a perishable wreath but we
an imperishable and a crown that will
not perish so I do not run
aimlessly nor do I box as though beating
there see he Likens it to
boxing you see
it everyone seeing
scripture nor do I box as though beating
the air so he Likens it to boxing but I
punish my body enslave it so that after
proclaiming to others I myself should
not be disqualified you see what he's
saying and I'll explain to you the
wisdom in fasting but let me read what
our Lord says John 153 you have already
been cleansed by the word that I have
spoken to you you see the more you focus
on the words the more you meditate on
the words the less sinful
thoughts the more you pray your Rosary
or your prayers are our father the more
you'll be occupied with Godly things and
pure
things how can young people or a man
keep their way pure by guarding it
according to your word you see it and
here two more passages Philippians 48
the wisdom of repetitive prayers
repetitive singing repetitive fasting
and Bible meditation okay watch here
learn this please learn the discipline
finally brothers and sisters now the
Revis New Revis Standard fasion Version
is gender inclusive but forget about it
notice why you need to meditate on the
words of scripture do
meditative Bible study meditative prayer
fasting keep repeating here's why
whatever is true
whatever is Honorable whatever is just
whatever is pure whatever is pleasing
whatever is commendable if there's any
excellence and if there's anything
worthy of Praise think about these
things that's why you repeat the
prayers that's why you repeat the
songs that's why you repetitively read
the Bible because the more you're
thinking about the prayers the more
you're thinking about scripture the the
more your mind will be cleansed and
purified of evil and filth because
you're told meditate on that what is
true what is Honorable what is righteous
what is pure what pleases God what is
praiseworthy what is
excellent everyone with me there right
there everyone catching
it why repetitive
prayer repetitive Bible study repetitive
fasting and worship because the more
you're consumed with those things the
less time you'll have to think about
impure things dishonorable things wicked
things that's true laziness idleness are
means of which Satan uses you to plunge
into
sin we seeing it guys I can't move on
I'm doing it for you guys here two more
Romans 121
and2 see the Bible has all the answers
Romans 12: 1-
2 I appeal to you therefore for brothers
brother sisters on the basis of God's
mercy to present your bodies as a Living
Sacrifice you see it's spiritual
training it's spiritual discipline it's
spiritual calisthenics spiritual
weightlifting spiritual
boxing that's what it is oppose your
body resist your body subjugate your
body Den well how do you do
that well that requires discipline and
God has giving you the spiritual
exercises to then become spiritually
muscular so you can conquer your fleshly
desires prayer fasting singing Eucharist
Bible meditation Church Holy and
acceptable God which is your reasonable
act of worship you
see we all priests
priestesses priests priestesses called
to offer sacrifices but we don't offer
animal sacrifices we
offer ourselves as sacrifices on the
altar of God here it is present your
body as Living Sacrifice now here's
another thing do not be conformed to
this age watch but be transformed by the
renewing of the mind you see why you do
repetitive
prayers how do you renew your mind how
do you cleanse your mind how do you
purify your mind to start thinking God's
thoughts and having the mind of God and
the attitude of God
how do you do it by focusing on the
things of God his words his Commandments
the Bible stories the prayers the
singing see
it so that you may discern what is the
will of God what is good and acceptable
and
perfect the more you focus and think and
reflect on God's
will the less you will sin the less
polluted you will be the less tempted
you'll be to conform to the world and
the more christm minded you'll become
you got it
now see it
there yeah metania means to repent we
know that Valerian change of mind metin
in the Greek means to have a change of
mind yes thank you Valerian all right so
you see it right now one more
one here is is the
key Psalm one happy are those who do not
follow the advice of the wicked or take
the path that siners tread or sit in the
seat of scoffers you see you are happy
you are blessed if you do not follow the
counsel of the wicked take their
advice right and you don't follow their
path and you don't sin among those who
are scoffers blasphemers revilers
debauches those who are living a
hedonistic party lifestyle don't sit
with them so who are the Blessed those
who Delight in the law of the Lord
yahwah and here's the key and in his law
they meditate day and night did you
catch the key
here they meditate day and night did you
catch it meditate on his law meditate on
his Commandments meditate on his words
meditate on the life of Jes Jesus and
the gospels meditate on the acts of the
Holy Spirit working through the apostles
in the book of Acts
meditate think of those things stop
meditating on
Netflix or prime Amazon Prime or Max or
Xbox or whatever less of that more of
meditating on the word word of the
Lord see and if you do that your mind
will be cleansed your desires will be
cleansed but you can't stop doing it
it's like training when I stop walking
and I start gorging I become an obese
slob again when you stop
weightlifting then you lose your
muscle definition when you stop doing
martial arts you're not as effective as
you used to be in the mat
right are you seeing the exercises that
God has given you to sin less and be
more like Christ are you seeing
it are you seeing everything you need is
in the
scriptures everything you need to be
successful and overcome Satan the Flesh
and the world is in the scriptures it's
applying what God has told you you must
do spiritual
training that we need to I mean I know
about losing weight and getting muscular
I don't do it because I'm
lazy now you know now you need to do and
then it says if you do all this you're
like a tree planted by streams of water
and we know in scripture the streams of
water the Holy Spirit John 7 3839 he is
the Fountain of Living
Waters which yield their fruit in season
notice your fruit is your righteous
deeds and their leaves do not wither and
all that they do they prosper in the
sight of God the wicked are not so see
how beautiful your Bible is How Majestic
your Bible is how glorious your Bible is
it's truly the word of God
you
see the wicked are not so but they are
like chaff that the wind drives away see
when I say separate the weed from a
chaff I'm using biblical metaphors
therefore the wicked will not stand in
the Judgment nor sinners in the
congregation of the righteous see you
will not dwell among the righteous with
the righteous before God for the Lord
yahwah Watches Over The Way of the
righteous see the lord loves the
righteous and their righteousness and he
keeps observing them because they will
dwell with him
but the way the Wicked Will perish they
will not stand before him